this morning clark county started the
long process to build a formal memorial
to those affected
by the one october tragedy committee
members involved in this say it could
take several
years for the project to actually be
built and right now the committee is
simply seeking public input
the hope is to honor victims and
survivors while also highlighting how
the community came together on las vegas
darkest night
since the process just started questions
on funding and a location
are still a long way from being answered
i think it's going to be a very
emotional journey
but in that is a healing journey
we want to make sure that we do it right
we don't want to rush it but we also
want to be respectful of time
this of course is going to be separate
from the healing garden downtown
60 people were killed in the one october
attack three years ago however today
a group of survivors and family of
victims
asked this new committee to keep the
death toll at 58.
they believe that that number represents
the 58 people who did not get to return
home
on one october